اذا ازمه هي الاسوا منذ
1993 ليست حرب اوكرانيا شتاء بحد ذاتها
وانما تداعياتها على من شنت تلك العمليه
العسكريه نتحدث عن روسيا تلك الدوله التي
تصنف التاسعه عالميا من حيث عدد السكان
باتت تشكو من قله العماله وسوق التوظيف
قاب قوسين او ادنى من عدم تحقيق اي تقدم
مرجو هي الحرب دائما هكذا لابد ان تستنزف
الاطراف المتنازعه ليس فقط بالدمار الذي
تشهده مناطق نوصفت في اوكرانيا كم مجزره
بوتشا التي مازالت تبكي اشلاها حتى الان
فروسيا ايضا لابد ان تتحمل ضريبه عمليتها
العسكريه على ارضها كيف ذلك صحيفه وسط جون
الامريكيه اوضحت ان الرئيس بوتن يحاول ان
يشد قدته على الاقتصاد بشكل اكبر ببساطه
مفتاح تمويل الحرب وضخ الاموال في شركات
تصنيع الاسلحه ومشهبه دعونا نفكك المقاله
لتتضح الصوره اكثر عما يجري في موسكو
تحديدا اعلان التعبئه الجزئيه قبل ثلاثه
اشهر واستدعاء نحو 300,000 جندي ما قبل
هذا النبا لم يكن الروس داخل البلاد
يفكرون بما يجري خارج حدود بلادهم او ربما
حتى منازلهم الى ان جاء هذا الخبر
كالساعقه على البعض هنا بدات روسيا تعاني
ازمه دي مجرافيا نزوح جماعي وحدود مقتضده
هاجروا بلادهم لاسيما اولئك الشباب هربا
من ان يجبر على القتال فذهبوا للبحث عن
فرص عمل في بلدان اخرى
حيث يمثل المتخصصون في مجال التكنولوجيا
خمس المجموعه وفقا لشركه هدهد هانتر
المعنيه بالوظائف في روسيا ما يعني ان
تطوير الانتاج المحلي ومصانع الاسلحه لم
يعد سريعا مهما حاول بوتن ان يتكي عليه من
اجل تحقيق اهدافه
[موسيقى]
فحسب وزاره الماليه الروسيه اظهرت
البيانات انا نفقات الدفاع ارتفعت بنحو 30
بالمئه مقارنه بعام 2021 الى حوالي 78
مليار دولار بالتاكيد استمرار الحرب يعني
ان هذه الارقام مرجحه بزياده وما يحول ذلك
ويقود جهود تغذيه الحرب تتدخل فيه ايضا
تلك العقوبات الغربيه كاخر حزمه فرضت
عليها بيعه نفسها الخام للبرميل الواحد
مقابل 60 دولار انا علما بان الاورال
الروسي هو شريان اقتصادي لداخل البلاد
اماما ذلك وباعتراف بوتن ببعض او اوجه
القصور او وجه القصور قرر ان يجبر بعض
الشركات الخاصه على المشاركه بانتاج معدات
للجيش وان كانت بعيده كل البعد تلك
المنتجات لكن مساعده القوات اصبحت هدفا
وطنيا
في مجلس الدومه اوضح الشهر الماضي انهم
يخططون لبناء مصانع جديده كلها تلبي
احتياجات القوات المسلحه وقال ان بوتين
ناقشا مع ايرالفاجون ذا فود وهي اكبر شركه
عالميه لتصنيع الدبابات في تسريع الانتاج
مؤكدا انها اوامر صارمه للدفاع عن روسيا
اما نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسي يوري بورسي
بوريسي فاقر بان الصناعات تواجه مشكله في
القوى العامله في المصنع الذي يعمل فيه
حوالي مليون شخص ويفتقر الى 400,000 اخرين
وشدد المتحدث باسم الكرام لان على ان مجمع
الانتاج العسكري يخضع لاشد اجراءات مكافحه
الفساد صرامه في اي قطاعا من قطاعات
الاقتصاد وقبل سنوات كنبوت قد اخضع
المنتجات الصناعيه ذات التقنيات العاليه
لسيطره شركه قابضه كبرى تسمى راسك والتي
تسيطر على اكثر من 800 شركه
اليكم قصه رئيس شركه خاصه لتعلم كيف اشرك
بوتن الشركات الخاصه في هذه الحرب يقول
الكسندر بيردينينقوف مدير العلاقات
التجاريه للملابس لوريس وحقائب الاطفال في
امسك بسايبيريا انه تلقى مكالمه من مكتب
وزاره الدفاع الاقليمي وسالوه اذا ما كان
بامكانه تصميم حقائب ظهر بشكل سريع للقوات
التي يحشدونها فلم يكن رده الا بالاجاب
وبسعر مخفض لان ذلك واجب وطني لم يرغب في
الاستفاده منه ماديا على حد تعبيره يتابع
بير دينكوف حديثهم مؤكدا ان 60 خياطا
وضعوا اعمالهم جانبا وعملوا على مدار
اثنتي عشر ساعه بلا اي عطله لينتجوا سته
الاف حقيبه في غدوني اسبوعين
شركه اخرى للمعدات الطبيه تسمى التكنيكه
اشارت ايضا في او شاركت في المهمه التي
عفوا
اصبحت بنظرهم وطنيه وعلى لسان نائب مدير
الشركه قال في احدى المقابلات الاعلاميه
كالبلدي باسره تغيرت حياتنا لننفذ امر
الدفاع عن الدوله وعباره بعباره ملطفه رغم
الضغط الهائل يجب ان نعمل بجد
[موسيقى]
طارو موضوع